governs that president has pledged to
give his inheritance to the country's
youth saying they are the heirs of his
father who was at one time the world's
longest-serving president Ali Bongo
ondimba said that with the agreement of
his wife and children he'll give the
money he inherited to a foundation for
youth and education we asked professor
douglas yates from the department of
international and comparative politics
at the american university of paris what
he thought of the president's offer i
was surprised
frankly the bongo family has amassed a
huge fortune a lot of it overseas and
the question i asked is why why now but
certainly it's good news if he wants to
give his fortune what his chair of omar
bongos fortune which is currently in a
succession battle in france with 52
legitimate errors if he wants to give
that to the youth of Gabon good they
certainly need the money if you go and
look at the kinds of sources that in the
past 10 or 15 years have tried to record
what the fortunes of African dictators
are you would see him appear often in
the top 10 list
I'd seen figures like 5 billion which
are rounded to the billion for the whole
family but what I would say to try to
imagine this fortune is at $100 a barrel
and about 600 700,000 barrels a day
we're speaking of billions and billions
of dollars some of its in Switzerland
some of it is in Liston Stein some of
its in Luxembourg but a lot of its gone
into what's called the Bermuda Triangle
of offshore banking in the Caribbean and
so this fortune is controlled by his
older half-sister Pascaline Pascaline
Bongo she was educated in finance she's
the one who managed the fortune overseas
and since he hasn't been able often to
locate the source of funds this might
all be a call of her bluff and an
attempt to finish the success and
succession battle and also identify
where the money is the last time I heard
something like this was when Bill Gates
said he want
to give away his fortune I don't know if
he's let go of it yet he's given away a
lot and I think I would be suspicious
that anyone would simply give away
everything that they have and since much
of this fortune has still not been
traceable it's possible that he might be
doing a symbolic gesture to try to
diminish the judicial processes that are
going on in France and the United States
unloading the obvious assets while using
that as a smokescreen to hide the others
Omar Bongo his father when he came to
his final days went to estates in
Barcelona and a hospital in Barcelona no
one had been talking about the bongos
family's estates in Barcelona there was
a lot of money billions of dollars
spread all around I certainly don't
believe he's going to give it all away